[موسيقى]
يروى ان صيادا رمى غزالا واخطاه فارسل في
اعقابه كلبه
لياتيهم ولما صار قاب قوصين من الطريده
التفت الغزال اليه ساخرا وقال لا تتعب
نفسك ولا تلهك فانك لن تدركني مهما فعلت
تحداه الكلب وقال له امهلني دقائق لاجعل
عنقك تحت قدم سيدي غنى الغزال مزهوا وقال
لاجل هذا لن تدركني فانا اعدو لنفسي وانت
تعدو لسيدك الى
العناوين اعلام القاهره يشوه سمعه الشعب
والبرلمان والحكومه والعمله الوطنيه
والتعليم
صالح تلوينه لحكومه حوثيه وهادي يرفض
خارطه الطريق بلغه
الجسد المفتي حسون يكذب الاذان والعيون
ولا يتوب في زمن
يوتيوب الكلب المسعور يستعد لدخول
البنتاجون فهل
تستدبروها
ويمنعون
فيروز
مرحبا لم يقبل بعض الاعلاميين في القاهره
ان تمر زياره الرئيس السيسي هذا الاسبوع
لابو ظبي دون اجتهاد وتشويش عليه فاكد ان
الملك سلمان الذي كان في زياره ايضا
للعاصمه الاماراتيه سيلتقي بالرئيس السيسي
غادر الزعيمان دون اي لقاء او اتصال
لتشتغل التحليلات وتشتعل التفسيرات
لكن بعض المحللين را او ان تعذر اللقاء
امر عادي ولا علاقه له بتصويت مصر مع
القرار الروسي بشان حلب ولا بقرار محكمه
مصريه استرداد تيران وصنافير ولا بمشاركه
مصر في القمه الافريقيه العربيه التي
قاطعتها الرياض ولا بمواقف وزير الخارجيه
سامح شكري المجافاة
ولا برفع مصر مستوى تنسيقها مع ايران ولا
بدعم السيسي العلني للنظام السوري
وجيشه كل ما في الامر ان هناك تضاربا بين
رزنامتي الملك سلمان والرئيس السيسي حاله
دون لقائهما ونقطه على
السطر الاعلامي ابراهيم عيسى قرر من
القاهره ان السعوديه غزت مصر غزوا كاملا
السعوديه غزت مصر غزوا كاملا وكليا
سيطره السلفيه والوهابيه عبر الثلاث شرايح
اللي اشتغلت عليها السعوديه على شريحه
السلفيين اللي هم بقى جماعه اثار السنه
المحمديه لغايه ما نوصل لبرهامي والدعوه
السلفيه في اسكندريه الاخوان المسلمين
بعلاقات تحالف وتمويل ودعم واحتضان في
السعوديه اصلا من بعد ما طردهم عبد الناصر
او من بقي منهم يعني والحاجه الثالثه اللي
العلاقه ما بين اليار الاسلامي المسلح
الارهابيين والمتطرفين اللي سموهم جهاديين
لما اخترعته السعوديه تماما اعلام القاهره
الذي تفرغ الاسبوع الماضي للهجوم على قناه
الجزيره بسبب بثها وثائقي العساكر واتهمها
بالعبث بسمعه الجيش المصري اشتغل هذا
الاسبوع على تشويه سمعه البرلمان المصري
والحكومه والعمله الوطنيه والاستقرار
الاجتماعي والاقتصادي ومستوى التعليم وحتى
تعاطي الشعب للمخدرات
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
بصراحه يعز علي ان انا اقول ان انا اضحكم
على برلمان بلدي بس هو
للاسف دي الحقيقه جمارك النهارده حضرتك
بتغلي ناقص تغلي الهوا اللي انا بشمه ايه
هو اللي ما حصلش في مصر لم يتحرك ايه
الحاجه الوحيده حد يقدر
يقوللي
مرتبات الناس والله لو قلنا من هنا للصبح
هو الدولار فلت ومحدش قادر عليه طرطره
كبيره جدا وعمل فعل فاضح مع الجنيه ربنا
يستر على الجنيه بتاعنا 50% من المصريين
ماعرفوش يقراوا يكتبوا وان اظن في 25%
متعلمين بس كذب يعني ما يعرفش يقرا ويكتب
برض يبقى 25% من المصريين هم بيعرفوا
يفكوا الخط يعني او 30% بالكتير الحمله
المروريه دي وقفوا ما يقرب من 210 سائق
يجدوا ايه
182 يعني حوالي دخلت في
90% شاربين
مخدت بهدلتونا يا جماعه يعني فيلم العساكر
صار قصيده مديح بالمقارنه مع هذا الكلام
ولا نسمح لانفسنا
باعادته اخيرا اخذت العداله مجراها في
قضيه جهاز الكفته المعالج للايدز واصدر
القضاء المصري حكما بالحبس سنه غيابيا على
الدكتور محمد فتوح رئيس جمعيه اطباء
التحرير بتهمه سبه فريق جهاز الكفته
بقياده اللواء ابراهيم عبد العاطي صاحب
الاختراع الخالد والفيديو التاريخي الذي
اوجد مفهوما جديدا للكوميديا العربيه باخد
الايدز من مريض بغذي المريض على ايدز بديه
له صبع كفته يتغذى عليه باخد المرض واديه
له غذاء وهذا قمه الاعجاز العلمي اشكر
السيد
المشير الذي اهتم بهذا البحث وكان كرباج
لانه قال قوالت ماصوره بترن في ودني حتى
الان قال احنا في الديل مش هينفع نمشي زي
الناس ما ماشيه احنا عايزين نقفز وهذه
القفزه الاولى ان شاء
الله صار للحوثيين وزاره رئيس ونائب و 4
وزيره فتحوا في اليمن مغاره ومعهم صالح
حصان وستاره ينسى النصير يطعن الجاره
بالامس وصفهم شرذمه صغيره خائنه عميله
مجرمه اجيره مردين في تعطه الخارجين عن
النظام لا افهم ولا استلمت لهم طلب على
الاطلاق الا شتائم وكلام ومش عارف ايه
وشعار الموت لامريكا
والاسرائيل الموت لامريكا والاسرائيل فين
في مران والزامات الذين يريدون ان تعود
عقارب الساعه الى الخلف لعوده
الامامه الكهنوتيه الرجعيه العنصريه لا
مصالحه ولا مداهنه ولا وقف للحرب الا بعد
نهايه هذه الشرذمه الباغيه المتمرده
الخائنه العميله واليوم يحالفهم في خندق
واحد بعد ان رماهم بكل المفاسد كل
الطواغيت تقاتل لمجد با
وصالح يقاتل نيابه عن سيد هذا الكلام لن
ينطوي على انصار الله انصار الله نحن
وياهم في خندق واحد الحكومه الحوثيه سقطت
بعد دقيقتين على تشكيلها في بحر من سخريه
اليمنيين الظرفاء ونال وزير الرياضه حسن
زيد حصه الاسد من النكه عليه لكنه تقبلها
اضحك الاخرين او اسعاد الاخرين وهذا جائز
ومباح لانهم لم يتناولون في عرضي لم
يتناولون في شرفي لم نا في كرامتي انا
يمكن اسهمت في توزيعها كل ما وصلني من
نكته وكنت اضحك فعلا من بعضها وللمقارنة
جلوس هذه الغريبه اعطيت لها تفسيرات طبيه
لدى بعض المغرضين لكن الارجح ان هادي اراد
ان يعبر بلغه الجسد عن رفضه لخريطه طريق
الحل الدوليه التي تساوي بين الشرعيه
والانقلاب الاحلى من هذا ان فوق الرئيس
هادي صوره للرئيس هادي وهذه ما حدا سبقك
عليها يا هادي في الميدان اليمني توقيت
للمعارك يشتغل
وفق القاط وتخزينه ناشط يمني تحدث
للكاميرا عن مواقيت الحرب والقط الحرب ما
تبدا الا من الساعه اتين بعد الظهر من
الوقت الذي يتناولوا فيه القات اما بقيه
الاوقات تلقاهم مخدرين ولذلك في هذه
الاوقات تكون الحرب اشد ضراوه شرسه هل
يكرر الحوثيون فعلتهم باطلاق صاروخ بالستي
على مكه المكرمه ممثلون يمنيون وثقوا
الجريمه على طريق
في قالب
كاريكاتوري الله اكبر الموت لامريكا الموت
الاسرائيل الا نس على اليهود دعني امر يا
اخ الصواريخ ويحك يا حامل البارود
والمتفجرات من اين اتيت والى اين انت ذاهب
انا ذاهب الى حال سبيلي الى حيث امرني ربي
ان تاتي الى مكه المكرمه لتقتل المسلمين
هذه مكه نعم هذه مكه المكرمه لبيك اللهم
بعمره لقد اتيت لكي اع تامر كذبت وهذا
الموتى الذي تحمله بين يديك طريقي الى جده
الى مطار الملك خالد وهناك مسلمون وحجاج
لبيت الله تقتلهم عد من حيث اتيت من ارسلك
انا الا تقرا مدئ يمن انا يمني جيرانكم
يمن
ايران عينك عينك كما يقول السوريون نفى
مفتي سوريا احمد بدر الدين حسون امام
البرلمان الار دي ان يكون قد هدد اوروبا
بعمليات ينفذها على ارضها استشهادي وهذا
ما الان يتحدثون عنه في الاعلام انني قلت
سارسل ارهابيين
الى
اوروبا ليفجر انفسهم لا ادري لماذا يكذبون
في الترجمه كذاب كذاب كذاب من كذاب كذاب
كذاب كذاب كذاب الذين تجروا وكذبوا سماحه
المفتي استندوا الى الفيديو التالي
المتداول على نطاق فلكي في موقع يوتيوب
اول قذيفه على
سوريا
فلبنان
وسوريا سينطلق كل واحد من ابنائها وبناتها
ليكونوا
استشهاديين على ارض اوروبا
وفلسطين واقولها لكل
اوروبا قولها
لامريكا سنعد استشهاديين هم الان عندكم ان
قصفت سوريه او قصفت لبنان فبعد اليوم
العين بالعين والسن بالسن واضح التزوير
الفيديو مفبرك وكذلك الترجمه رغم عدم وجود
ترجمه لكنها
مفبركه المهم عثرنا على النسخه الاصليه
للخطاب الذي زور زورا ونسب لحسون وتبين ان
الفيديو يعود لشخص من قبيله الخزرج يدعى
عبد الله بن ابي بن سلول نعرضه مع الاشاره
الى انه لم يتسنى لنا التاكد من صحه
الفيلم من مصادر مستقله في قريش اول قذيفه
على
سوريا
فلبنان
وسوريا سينطلق كل واحد من ابنائها وبناتها
ليكونوا
استشهاديين على ارض اوروبا
وفلسطين في الرقه يتساءل البعض هل يتوقع
صدور قرار عن تنظيم الدوله يقضي بتخفيض
عدد لاعبي فريق كره القدم الى 10 حتى لا
يكون عددهم اداع
داعش كذلك يتساءل البعض هل من الحكمه ترك
شبكه الانترنت تحمل دون اي عائق الفيلم
الامريكي
بجدادي رغم تشابه اسمه مع اسم بغدادي
بغدادي
لعبادي رئيس وزراء العراق استاذ
حيدر ضعيف ضعيف جدا بحسب نوري المالكي
رئيس الوزراء السابق الذي طالب برحيله ما
بده يشوف وجه بالحكومه فور الانتهاء من
معركه
الموصل هلا ليس دفاعا عن العبادي لكنه هو
الذي يقود معركه الموصل التي فر منها
المالكي المالكي وفي مقابله نشرتها
الصحيفه الامريكيه ول ستريت جورنال دعا
الى تشكيل حكومه جديده تعارض الطائفيه
ومعروف عن المالكي انه اكثر شيئين بكرههم
بحياته الطائفيه
والمذهبيه الذين قتلوا الحسين لم ينتهوا
بعد هاهم اليوم
موجودين والحسين بلون الاخر لا يزال
موجودا هو الذي يستهدف من قبل هؤلاء
الطغات اذا انصار يزيد وانصار الحسين مره
اخرى وعلى طول الخط يصطدمون في مواجهه
شرسه
عنيده وهذا يعطينا رؤيه بان الجريمه التي
ارتكبت بحق الحسين لم تنتهي وانما لازالت
فصولها التي نعيشها اليوم ابو عزرائيل
صديق نور
يتدمر من سياسيي العراق وعلى طريقه بابا
نويل وزع الهدايا على من قيل في وسائل
التواصل انهم اطفال عائلات سنيه نازحه من
الموصل لبيك يا
حسين لبيك يا
[موسيقى]
علي وين
البن ابو سيدك روح يلا روح قول لبيك يا
علي مال مش هذا جين مال مشك مع شطك اخذ
لحيتي يلا قولوا لبيك يا علي لبيك عل وفي
العراق ما يزال الجدل قائما حول وثيقه
التسويه والمصالحه التي اطلقها السيد عمار
الحكيم الوثيقه رفضت على نطاق واسع وهذا
النائب فائق الشيخ علي يطرحها على المزاد
العلني ولا يشتريها بربع دينار انا اذا
اجاني فت فقير بالشارع من المحتمل ام
لمحفظه المحتمل اطلع مثلا افرض 25 مثلا من
تقي هاي التسويه بيت فقير يجيني اقولها
شنو بدك يقوللي ورقه التسويه اقله
دقيق هذا ايش قد هذا ربع دينار لو كان ما
بيدك الورقه كان اعطيتك ذاك يعني التسويه
تس ربع هوايه ا دقيقه انا ما ادري اكو
اصغر من ال لا هو
ربع
عندما يختار دونالد ترامب الكلب المسعور
وزيرا لدفاعه او لحروبه المقبله فهذا يعني
ان ما كان في هذا العالم بعد اليوم
للقطط وقديما قيل مع بعض التعديل اذا لم
تكن ذئبا اكلتك الكلاب فقد اختار الرئيس
الامريكي المنتخب ترامب الجنرال المتقاعد
جيمس ماتس وزيرا للدفاع في ادارته المقبله
اما سر تلقيبه في الصحافه الامريكيه
بالكلب المسعور فيعود الى مشيته المختال
التي اكتسبها في معاركه بالعراق
وافغانستان والى لغته الفضه في الجنديه
ومع وسائل
الاعلام هل انت تطلق لحيتك وتتنقل عبر
المطارات هل اعتقدت احيانا ان الذي يرن
اثناء فحصك في جهاز الكشف الامني هو شعر
لحيتك وليس المعادن التي تحملها هل فكرت
بتغيير اسمك لتنفي عن نفسك تهمه الارهاب
سكيتش تمثيلي يحاكي ما يعانيه بعض
الملتحين في مطارات
[موسيقى]
الغرب
اصبر
لا والله
فيك حام اسح خليني
اشرحلك
ير
يا سيد جورج جورج جورج نعم جور اسمك
جورجيه ما قلتلي اسمك جورج من الاول اهلا
وسهلا اهلا وسهلا فيك سيد جورج اهلا وسهلا
فيك لا تاخذنا حبيب قلبي لاخذنا تفضل روح
البيت ح روح البيت روح البيت حبيب قلبي
اهلا وسهلا فيك اهلا وسهلا ما في مشكله ما
مشكله اهلا وسهلا اهلا وسهلا اب محمود ابو
محمون مين ابو محمود انا ابو محمود و كيف
ابو محمود ما قلتلي اسمك جورج انا اسمي
جورج وابو محمود وكيف صارت انا عندي ست
اخوه بنات واهلي كان نادرين ندر انه اذا
بيهم صبي بدهم يسمو جورج وجيت انا عن جد
يعاد
[موسيقى]
التفتيش حزب الله منع في الجامعه
اللبنانيه اطلاق اغاني السيده فيروز
مقتطفات من تقرير لقناه الجديد ونعود لي
المره الاولى وربما لن تكون الاخيره التي
يمنع فيها حزب الله الاغاني حيث يكون وهذا
ما حدث لزملاء الطالب في كليه الهندسه
محمد حميدي الذي توفي في الث3 من تشرين
الاول بحدث سير عندما قرروا في الكليه
الاحتفال بعيد ميلاده في الباحه فمنعوا
بسبب تخلل الذكرى اطلاق اغاني
لفيروز عزيزي حزب الله للانصاف طلابك من
زاويه معينه ربما يكون تصرفهم مالوف في
العالم الاس اسلامي فليس من العدل اجبارهم
على سماع الموسيقى وغناء النساء اذا كان
في ذلك حرج شرعي بالنسبه لهم والارجح ان
الكثير من المسلمين يتفهمون ما فعله طلابك
في
الجامعه لكن فعلهم هذا يندرج وفق
التعريفات العالميه الجديده ضمن قائمه
سلوك
داعشي وانت قدمت نفسك في لبنان على انك
حزب حر
وبانك تقاتل الارهاب خلف الحدود لانه يريد
ان يفرض افكاره وبرنامجه على الناس فكيف
ينشد طلابك في الجامعه الحكوميه اناشيده
على الملا ويمنعون اغاني فيروز وا من رب
السماء لعلي الخامنائي
وا من رب
[تصفيق]
عطنا ايه
عيطنا ايه احكيلي احكيلي عن بلدي يحكيلي
يا ناسم اللي مارق ع الشجر مقابيلي عن
اهلي حكايه عن بيتي حكايه عن جار
الطفوله حكايه
طويلي
ا
احكيلي
احكيلي ختاما ماذا يعرف المواطنون العرب
عما يجري الان في مدينه حلب التي منع
الفيتو الروسي والصيني هذا الاسبوع سريان
هدنه فيها لسبعه ايام حب عابر للحدود
وصرخه غضب في وجه سلاطين الدماء واحنا
بنشعر بالمراره والحركه والحزن على ما
يجري في حلب عم بصير مزره حقيقيه يعني وين
الامه العربيه لا يوجد عربي قادر على
مواجهه ما يحدث في حلب قلوب الشعب العربي
الشريف المسلم الطاهر كل قلوبها معكم
بنقول الله يصبركم على اللي انتم فيه وان
شاء الله يفرجها عنكم وما لهم غير الله
ودعاوي الناس ان شاء الله ربك بحلها
الحلقه انتهت اما محارق المدن فمتعلق جمع
لها الحطب من الشرق والغرب لكنها ستنطفئ و
وتنتهي حتما
ستنتهي الى اللقاء يا رايحين لحالك حبي
معكم راح يا
محملين العين بتحتي العين
التفاح يا رايحين لحالك حتين معكم راح را
يا
محملين العيد
بتحت العيد بتتب
كل من واليفه مع وانا والي فراح يا رب ناس
مهاوى ترد الوف
[موسيقى]
ليا